I grew up really really poor my mom and
I didn't really have much one year in
high school was particularly hard she
was single mom and didn't make a lot of
money we weren't gonna make much of that
Christmas Eve because there was not much
we can do with it we sat down on
Christmas Eve to a very simple dinner
and we heard a knock at the door it was
a pastor from our local church and his
family they were holding boxes and boxes
of food that they had brought for us ham
eggnog
basically everything you need for a
Christmas dinner they heard about her
situation through the grapevine and put
together a food drive to give us a
better Christmas my mom and I just kind
of stood there in disbelief and cried
and were so shocked we couldn't speak
other than just to say thank you then he
came in that everything down how Dustin
left I'll never forget the moment I'll
never forget the moments I'll always
remember the moment we closed the door
and cried and just looked at each other
with tears in her eyes unable to say
anything
sometimes there's good people in this
world and you just don't expect them to
come for you and then we
went to the kitchen and started cooking
what would be the best Christmas dinner
probably I've ever had it has to be the
best Christmas I've ever had
Wow